I think every rookie makes mistakes and
certainly so did Alan as well the big
difference though is that most people
are fortunate enough to do that within
you know there are pre-production
rehearsals or whatever Alan did it on
his first show on the first leg of the
Rihanna tour in front of 70,000 people
when it comes to making music I try to
no budget it's a full-time job you know
give up because we never know once we
start is around the corner that's
exactly what happened to me
what's that belief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
and I want to see that great thing that
you have inside of you come out so you
can help change the world so to help you
on your journey today we're gonna learn
from record producer and DJ Alan Walker
and my take on his top ten rules of
success rule number eight is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always
guys as you're watching if you hear
something that really resonates with you
please leave it down the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
yourself as well enjoy
I started making music back in 2012 ish
I was beautifully music because I was
tired of the mainstream stuff I wanted
to find something else I would actually
like and enjoy I listen to that
discovered is a youtuber who went by the
name didn't us I decided to leave a
comment on this YouTube video because
I'm very interested in learning how
those things actually work how do people
that make what we listen to or we use
like the folks on my website and
graphics the music and therefore I was
very interested in like how did he do it
then we started to get in touch even
more and more none he started teaching
me the basics of music production making
it through that first performance I
guess was in many ways a relief but we
also quickly realized there was a lot of
work to be done and a lot of
improvements that had to be made with
the full-scale festival tour throughout
Europe just eight weeks away well we
really had to get our grind on also
super-nervous I was like oh my god I
can't believe I'm doing this
[Music]
we basically had all the festivals that
we wanted that summer Tomorrowland green
fields Lollapalooza we had a solid plan
for the whole summer
[Music]
then came the phone call hi guys we got
a call from the US does Ally want to do
support on a Rihanna tour I was like
okay can't say no to this
do I really dare to say yes I think
every rookie makes mistakes and
certainly so did Alan as well the big
difference though is that most people
are fortunate enough to do that within
you know there are pre-production
rehearsals or whatever Alan did it on
his first show on the first leg of the
Rihanna tour in front of 70,000 people I
was unlucky and actually hit the cue
button on one of the songs and I messed
up that wasn't supposed to happen
Alan in that part of his career that it
was should be doing mistakes I hate
myself for every mistake that I make but
I also know that making mistakes and
learning from them is an important part
of the process if I didn't make any
mistakes then I probably wouldn't have
been where I am today when it came to me
the decision between choosing to work
without a music or stay in school it was
pretty hard because it was a 50/50
chance either I would succeed with the
music or I would have to go back to
school
pretty much and so I took the risk and
the I want all in for a music so yeah it
was really important decision and I
think it was worth it when it comes to
making music I look at it's a full-time
job it's a hobby because I think I will
get more pressure on myself if I look at
a job so I hope it's more easier to die
avoided pressure and be more creative I
wrote something down for that I think
it's your bias I think everything
started out with people or rather
nicknames from around the world have
helping each other out so can you
explain a little bit more hey well back
in 2012 when I first started to make
music I got in touch with for example
producers from Spain Canada Australia
Chile and pretty much around the whole
world and we made Facebook groups for
example I addressed where we could sit
down discuss music
get tips and tricks' what we should do
what we should not do we want to come to
music production and and work really
really great and it's been a really
really good health for me actually
establishing myself as an artist and
also learning things on the road
especially like you say yeah the
beginning as a musician and then were
you surprised by this community yeah
because that's what I was i well that
was the first thing that I got
introduced to and
and it was really good help because the
majors starting out with pretty much
nothing I just got in touch with people
that way what was really really good for
me as an artist what kind of tips that
they give or if there may be one thing
that sticks out that you kind of got
from those groups
hey well one thing then they happen it
was for example changing my artist name
I used to be go by the name de Vaux and
we were just discussing like should I
change my name from D Vokes to other
walks Walker Walker or something else
they all agreed upon
EGC green name our Walker and that's for
example one thing that happened and I
also when I first released fade for
example they gave me feedback before I
release did and the pretty much with all
my other songs as well and it's been
true out because they gave me feedback
and they were just trying to be as
honest I'll stay here it can be and I
think that it's a very good thing
because I learned so much just by
getting honest criticism and stuff
people say just saying oh yeah it's good
so yeah you know give up because we
never know once we start this around the
corner that's exactly what happened to
me I just kept on uploading songs and
songs and songs you use your channel to
my song Club page and I got picked up a
no corporal sons and that's where it all
started and I was the dream of c major
key for my success i know like motion
picture soundtracks like really inspire
you with your music but how do you keep
that mindset when you're creating music
do you I mean you can listen to any of
your tracks and I could put it on to any
film so how do you keep that mindset
going I don't actually know I'm just
trying to make whatever I like what am I
thinking that's listenable because I'm
thinking like as long as the amenities
are good then this song is pretty much
good to go because I'm a very a guy that
really cares but the melodies in a song
because I feel like the number one most
important thing in the song instead
melodies if the melodies are in goodand
I don't know if 50 audience would listen
to it so but yeah we're alone and faded
like the melody has been quite simple
but also very catchy so I think that's
also what's catching the audience you
like to say unrecognizable to a certain
extent so why is that it is just a
symbol health unity promotion and like
just to tell anyone that they can be a
walker they can accomplish anything like
and what we also did it in my Brian a
music video for alone like it was that
we wanted to send out a very powerful
message and that was like just including
so many other people on any music video
instead of having one person or three
people as in a single asleep and faded
and we just wanted to like have it in a
way like that everyone is connected but
also like just sound out message that
you're not alone because you may feel
that you're alone but you're not
actually along I grew up
in the community and what I want to do
is to embrace the unity of the community
and that's why I wear a mask just to
symbolize and create unity all you have
to do is to run the mosque and hoodie it
become a walker just like me
Allen's visual image is born from his
four phones the gamers it's about this
like mystical identity with his hoodie
and his mask exam that's also like from
the gaming community that you're always
behind the screen there's something
between you and the others we want to
keep that and build something very
interesting by not telling everything
from the start
well part of this because you also were
interested in graphic design and so so
part of kind of this this new internet
culture is the way you present you'd
like to present yourself and so where
did this come from a graffiti son was
been pretty random because the mana was
even younger I downloaded Photoshop and
just started messing around making like
the signatures like people on forums
that I was in gaming with like you can
have a signature where a picture that
said your username so I kept on making
those with a transparent background and
people really liked them and then later
on I started to combine it with a
programming that I used to do before and
with a graphic design and I even got to
combine this with music production
because I also design my own logo and
and just all those things just fit
perfectly together and also focus on
making my own logo of being able to
actually give criticism to my own art or
carrying it were making the cover arts
for example from fading with the speed
alone extra like it's just like just by
doing this kind of stuff like I would
say like I would take a closer look at
the details because I used to do it
before myself and also said that always
having communists the programming part
like you have to program everything so
it yeah it fits it fits perfectly
together
my son came industry the promoter start
with that one of my alpha one for my
team
something malady they want me to like
work on a holiday and to the guild like
Andy Allen Walker vibe so we just
started to work on it and that we got
the easiest willing to sing demo workers
and they just kicked us in the beginning
we have like paralyzed is reversed piano
along with some parts actually the
vocals of law we actually chopped up we
walk or I made a proc think we're this I
combined with the piano in the beginning
is I created the Sun yeah that's right
apples for another I think just creates
the whole track
[Music]
in the first verse we kind of like
stones to build up the track so I try to
keep it simple some course blocks and
also muted guitars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we also unlike the solely that I also
used in for example fade texture and
faded like soft my sounds or something
made for most of the oceans that I use
or from plugins and when it comes to
plugins I mean here this is Nexus and
southern form inspire
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because suji Justine
barois asked me to if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you would like me to
profile next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote
I'd also love to know what did you learn
from this video that had the biggest
impact on you what lesson are you going
to take and immediately apply it somehow
in your life or in your business leave
it in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout-out to Braulio Damian
Calzado from surf bounce comm thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word taking that picture it
looks a little beaten around the top
like the top part of the cover is messed
up but I hope you're not reading and
driving at the same time pulled over to
have a read thank you so much for the
support we're taking the picture for
posting it I really appreciate it and
I'm so glad that you enjoyed the book
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
I just cannot try to do something new so
what I did was like I took a
electro/house track that I made that was
about 128 ppm to speed down to 90 BPM
satellite up open up the melodies and
they like the emotion come out easier
and what motivates me the most is the
great feedback that I get for my
followers
I'm really looking forward to releasing
new music because I really enjoy like
releasing new content to followers
unless nurse all around the world I
mainly learned to make view so you don't
need you because I never had like a
music background or anything so I just
stuck behind my computer for maybe a
year
just watching YouTube tutorials and
cleaned up and just kept on learning the
basics and new things I got in touch
with people Facebook for example in
music groups we just kept up giving each
other feedback the most important word
ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple
that would be to like a little beacon
hey believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details
[Music]